have you dealt with anxiety in your life
oh yeah well but but anxiety from
outside sources most of my anxiety I
finally realized that
you know and now that I can look back on
my life and you know with a with a you
know a little more perspective most of
my problems in fact all of my problems
and anxiety had to do with me being
trusting
and having people who I thought I could
trust not not be truthful and not be um
honest that that has been the source of
all my issues
um I try to be a nice person I try to uh
you know I try to treat people fairly I
try and I try to be as honest as I can
you know in a in a really dishonest
business
um you know if you know any gonna be
obviously you're in an entertainment
business you know it's the [ __ ] show
yeah so
um but that's where my my issues are my
issues are trusting people and having
them stab you in the back and having
them not not not be who you were hoping
they would be or at least giving you the
um you know the courtesy of uh of being
straightforward that that's that's a big
issue for me yeah I understand that it's
it's the worst business to be in when
you're looking for that because I come
from Humble origin where you know I grew
up in a small town and uh you know I
come out here and you just want to you
want to believe everybody you want to
think that everybody has your best
interest well they they all never have
your best interests it's what's for me
what how do I benefit from this person
and you know in your lifetime if you
meet a handful of people that you could
really trust and you know and know it's
unconditional the love and the you know
reciprocation you win but you have to
weed out a lot of times you have to go
through those things as you know more
than I do what was the was the hardest
time in your life really the end of the
80s sort of like find Reinventing
yourself going through a divorce what
was it that how empty or how low did you
actually get because I know you talk
about mental health but what were how
did Desperate did you become
well I talk about them in my book you
know I I wrote and I have an
autobiography called a great change of
seasons and I you know I talk about it
in the book I describe it yeah there was
an issue there was an issue with some uh
money and things like that
um and it was kind of a
I had you know and I'll I'll just say it
again I I I've been called down to a
meeting on Wall Street with uh with some
money managers who uh here again I had
been trusting for years and I found out
that um I didn't have what I thought I
had and it was kind of a wake-up call
and I remember
um you know kind of being shocked and it
was It was kind of an after hours
meeting in this big Wall Street you know
high-rise and and I remember the the
head of the firm you know this much
older guy you know he walked me out to
the elevator and he could tell I was you
know pretty shaken up and he said look
he said I know this is you know you
probably think this is you know the
worst thing that's ever happened to you
he goes but I'm going to tell you I
think it's going to be the best thing
that ever happened to
and with that the door the elevator door
open I got in the elevator and went
downstairs so I got in a cab my head up
to my apartment in the village and at
the time
um I was separated from my wife we were
about to get divorced and so I gave her
all the furniture there was nothing in
the apartment except the TV hit a bed it
was very depressing but before I got
there I was in the cab and as I was
riding up Uptown toward my apartment I
started getting pains in my chest
and I thought my and I had never had a
experience anything like that you got to
remember I was in my 30s yeah and
I I went oh my God
I'm gonna have a heart attack I'm gonna
die in the back of this cap
and I said this is [ __ ] up I said
diet by myself in the back of a cab at
night in New York City and I and I got
pissed off and I said I'm never gonna
let this happen to me and I but I had
pains in my chest look uh
spoiler alert it didn't happen
I want to let you know
um but anyway so but I went up to the
apartment and there it was this like
really depressing dark apartment with no
furniture and I'm standing there going
this is [ __ ] up I said I'm I'm gonna
I'm I'm do I don't know what I'm gonna
do but it's not going to be this and
that's when the whole thing started
that's when I started therapy that's
when I made the decision to leave New
York I sold everything I owned which was
considerable I had a lot of as they say
I might not have a lot of cash in the
back but I had a lot of [ __ ] right you
know I had apartments and a house in
Connecticut I had an airplane I had 50s
car collection I sold everything
literally wholesaled everything
um and I just moved to Colorado and
started over again that's where I met my
future wife that had a house I built a
house had a kid you know blah blah blah
you know that's amazing you think about
that stuff and you look back it's like
there's nothing more important than your
health I mean they always say health as
well I mean in the end it's like money
and all these other things they don't
they don't matter